hello out there welcome to the uplift we
got a great show for you and a great
cast of characters as always among them
these a man using his building skills to
help his particular Community we'll tell
you what practical everyday item he
makes There's the Man also a high school
student with autism who received a
special announcement during marching
band practice we'll explain and a
newborn baby who got a special middle
name from a stranger and how their
families went on to form a lifelong
connection
plus a senior home using a very unique
solution to combat a very common
Staffing shortage problem in this
country who or should we say what is
filling in go ahead make your best guess
we'll resolve it for you plus a sweet
moment from Bindi Irwin that honored her
father that would be the late Steve
Irwin there's little daughter Grace and
of course more of our heartwarming
videos the ones you just gotta see
you're watching The Uplift
[Music]
welcome welcome come one and all of the
uplift the show that lifts you up for at
least the next 30 minutes you and me as
well me that would be Tony to cope but
we've got a great show for you today and
we're going to start you off with a man
in Denver who found a unique way to help
his community Caitlin O'Kane has his
story
James Warren was walking in his Denver
neighborhood when something gave him
pause a woman was waiting for the bus
sitting in the dirt and I was like oh
man that sucks you know that's not
dignified at all
um we need to be doing better by our uh
you know fellow City members and so I uh
I thought I could do something about
that I could build a bench he found some
scrap wood and because he grew up around
tools he knew he could muster up a bench
he built one and put it back at that bus
stop where he first got the idea
since then he's built eight custom
benches and has placed them at bus stops
around the area what's been really cool
is seeing other people online building
their own benches or even just taking
chairs that they were going to throw out
or maybe found that somebody else was
throwing out and putting them by bus
stops instead of letting them go to
landfill each bench is different but
James makes sure to include this same
message on all of them be kind
sometimes it's difficult to to really
make a change in the world around us or
it can feel really difficult to make a
change in the world around us but the
truth is that anyone can be kind and by
being kind you can make a difference in
the world around you and that difference
matters a lot and so just maybe a little
reminder to people
he's heard from several people in the
community those who use the benches and
those who have been inspired by them I
saw these posts like on Twitter and they
said I was inspired by you to build a
bench I was inspired by you to put out a
chair and that in turn inspires me
because it's cool it's no longer just
like one dude doing something for his
neighborhood it's uh
dudes and dudettes all over the
community doing things for their
neighborhoods so it's really inspiring
to see that he hopes the benches
continue you to inspire and perhaps
expand to other cities because one
person can make a difference but we're
more powerful when we come together
it's a bench Built for Two it's a great
story and our next one is a great story
as well it's about a baseball player who
went viral after making a major
accomplishment and his mom went viral
too Natasha larno has their story
mom I'm going to the Major Leagues
laughs
when Wynton Bernard found out he made it
to the Colorado Rockies after 10 years
into minor leagues he instantly called
his mom Janet
when I got to call her on the phone for
that first time she absolutely had to be
the first one because she's been there
for me every single step of the way
she's seen all the struggles I've been
through all the hard times losing my
father so to give my mom that news that
I was making it to the majors after all
this time was the greatest feeling in
the world but I got the call
I was a total shock because I didn't see
it coming and then I just started crying
I had kind of resigned myself to the
fact that went was going to be a career
minor Leaguer it just happened for him
and so it made
everything else that has happened to him
it kind of put it in the back seat at 31
years old he wondered if his time at the
top had passed him it started in high
school in terms of his struggle with a
coach that didn't believe in him and
when he went to him and said I'm I want
to play college baseball and the coach
replies
you can't even play high school baseball
and Winton steadfastly has always kept
his faith that he was going to do it it
wasn't all you know cherries and Roses
it was definitely some hard times where
you know I've been released a couple
times but I picked myself up and kept
working hard you know people always told
me that they didn't think I would make
it and I didn't listen to him I just
kept envisioning my dream and eventually
reaching it remembering how his mom
cared for his late father when he was
sick gives him the strength to move
forward
time to get hard in my workouts or when
I was struggling on the baseball field
when I felt like life was really hard
for me I would use my mom's strength and
then that would help me play better and
help me continue to grind and that's why
this story is such a Triumph it's such a
victory because it's like goodness well
I'm sorry
goodness well
um prevail
when your heart is right and you and you
really want something and you persevere
Wynton says he was going through his
pre-game routine when his manager made
the announcement that would change his
life forever
he goes boys after 11 hard minor league
Seasons when Bernard's headed to the
show and the whole locker room just
erupted everybody was clapping we're all
crying together I was over there beating
my chest I was picking my teammates up
everybody's hugging me there's been a
million people in my life who told me
you're never gonna make it or why are
you still playing baseball like you
should move on to something else and
imagine if I had listened to him I would
have never fulfilled my dream it was an
emotional day for Whitton followed by an
emotional phone call for his mom that
captured the hearts of Millions
you give me a lot of inspiration mom and
I promise I'm gonna keep working just as
hard
oh
some big league love there coming up
parents out there how did you come up
with your child's name one family chose
a name off of a handwritten letter that
they received at the hospital
I'll tell you what made them decide to
pick a name Based On A stranger's story
plus a sweet moment between Bindi Irwin
and her toddler little daughter Grace
there it's a moment that went viral
we'll show you what happened next
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the uplift we now have
those heartwarming videos the ones you
just need to see you're going to want to
share starting with this one from Bindi
Irwin who took her daughter Grace to
Australia Zoo and something caught
little Grace's eye
is he over here
yeah
Grandpa crocodile and he's in his
construction hat
yeah
you love Grandpa crocodile
that is bindy's daughter Grace looking
at a photo of her grandfather that would
be the late Steve Irwin bendy's dad and
Grace's grandpa or as she puts it
Grandpa crocodile
so sweet all right our next video
features another baby this one nine
month old Milo who made an effort to
sing take a look
[Music]
you are a singer I love that very sweet
letting it rip belting them out all
right five-year-old Auburn to our next
story built a skate ramp with her father
last year and then this summer she
started learning how to skateboard first
the ramp then the skateboard here she is
practicing with Dad
I'm scared to drop it
Dad I'm gonna try by myself but be there
to catch me if I need you okay I will
always stop to be here to catch you if
you need
Dad yeah I'm ready there to catch if she
needs I can see she's gonna drop in your
respect oh I got to see later whoa okay
let's try again okay
oh I almost didn't even need to get you
I will try again all right
I could stay with that all day but we
are going to move on to our next video
which might teach you a lesson do not
leave your car door open even if it's
just for a quick errand
are you crazy
get out of there
are you kidding me get out there's
nothing to eat in there
well we'll see about that Deputy Casey
thrower there with the Madison County
Sheriff's Department that's in Alabama
was delivering civil papers and came
back to his car to find those goats
there one goat on the roof one goat in
the car thrower said that uh he often
leaves his door open because he's got to
deliver a lot of these papers to a lot
of different homes and sometimes he's
got a retreat in a hurry because people
have dogs and dogs aren't always
friendly but goats goats is a first
coming up what's in the name well when
in Louisiana was named after an angel
what the meaning is behind his name
chosen by a stranger
plus made an extraordinary High School
senior who has mastered music and
excelled in engineering but it's his
outlook on life that's truly special
[Music]
when baby Kingston was born his parents
decided to go with a stranger suggestion
for a middle name years later she is no
longer a stranger she's a friend David
begno has their story
when this baby boy entered the world in
Lafayette Louisiana in 2018 his parents
Connie dispani and Benjamin Hall named
him Kingston but they didn't have a
middle name it came to them by chance in
the form of a handwritten letter that
they had received at the hospital
Kingston was just minutes old a
surveillance camera at Lafayette General
Medical Center captured a stranger
asking for directions so that she could
deliver that letter who was she to my
dad's Angel even though I will never
know your name you are the first child
born here
after my Dad's passing when one life is
taken another is given please keep my
dad in your prayers his name is James
thank you this was that stranger Jamie
Fontenot you see shortly after her
father 86 year old James Lee Grimmett
died in the hospital Jamie heard sweet
music
it's a lullaby that plays throughout the
hospital
families of newborns come here and they
press that button in the labor and
delivery Ward playing the lullaby
letting everybody know a newborn just
arrived on January 12 2018 Kingston Hall
was born right after Mr Grimmett died
the timing seemed more than coincidental
somebody said well then that's Dad's
angel
so with no escort you just took your
letter and I just took my letter and I
went to the ob unit I said my dad passed
away about 10 40. so give this to the
first baby that was born
after that time Dr Jennifer puglisi and
nurse Sydney begno received Jamie's
letter Dr puglisi gave it to Connie and
she started reading it silently and she
just had tears streaming down down her
face and
it was really beautiful I came in and
then the dad says oh we found our middle
name and I'm like great what is it and
he says well if James of course and I'm
like oh
of course my nurse followed me to that
side and she was like well
do you mind if we get your information
and give it to miss Jamie we asked
Connie do you remember who that nurse
was I know her name was I think Miss
Cindy Sydney Sydney yes I think it'll
sit with me Sydney so that's my mom
really
what a coincidence
that's awesome thank you Mom yes it was
my mom who helped to deliver baby
Kingston and then told me the story of
how a stranger wrote a letter to Connie
who then decided that the best middle
name for Kingston was James named in
honor of Mr grimmon
is
this
I'm so happy again
what happens to meet you
I just think I was going to meet you I
think I'd ever see you either
the best part for Jamie holding Kingston
James
oh
what are we
to take away from a story like this
family is everything
and if you don't have faith
you don't have anything you just never
know when a blessing is going to come
and fall in your lap so you all will
stay in touch oh yes of course of course
we all want to clap so we're just going
to clap
well that was four years ago
how are you now good good grief
everybody's great yes blessed blessed
[Music]
this is actually the first time they've
seen each other since the pandemic
started he got it mastered mom baby
Kingston just started Pre-K there you go
when you see him do you think about your
dad always yeah yes yeah always and my
name is Houston James Hall what does it
do for you when you hear him say his
name do you think about her dad yes and
how far he's came in Kingston he he
loves to say his name does he yes he'll
tell you I'm Kingston James Hall and I
said well go ahead baby I can't even
describe it because he's here and on top
of that he was blessed with an Angel
that's right he's right coming into the
world Jamie has been following every
Milestone even putting together a
special picture book for Kingston's
baptism he was 86 years old I wanted
something you know sort of set it in
stone that he could have through the
years that he could look back at when he
was born born and the story behind what
happened what's happened between the two
of you in the last four years well we've
we talk we text she sends pictures what
do you hope this story does for other
people share that good things still
happen
that strangers can become family they're
like everybody can come on one Accord
right and love one another
unconditionally without even knowing
each other that's it yes yes definitely
yeah
and having met David begno's mother
there in that piece I think you can all
see where David gets it it's a very
sweet story
all right coming up meet the
extraordinary High School senior who
received a very big announcement during
marching band practice
plus the unique and you might say
unusual solution for a staffing shortage
at a senior living facility what they
come up with find out after the break
[Music]
when a nursing home had a staffing
shortage recently they came up with an
interesting solution and it brought a
unique sense of Joy to the residents
there here's Omar via Franca
83 year old Jill Breckenridge has a new
friend at her Minnesota nursing home
it's not a person it's great to see you
it
is a special robot that can talk I hope
you are having a wonderful day and even
dance with the residents to keep them
active
but Pepper's special power is using new
technology to bring up old memories here
is her brother holding your puppy Jill
was diagnosed with Alzheimer's but when
pepper shows her pictures of her past
and I had red hair the memories come
flooding back I loved my horse Lucky
Strike warms my heart Sharon Fenn is
Jill's daughter she was smiling I know
I could tell from the back when I was
watching her she was beaming arshia Khan
with the University of Minnesota Duluth
is the brain behind the robots when you
saw Jill with pepper what did you learn
I was almost in tears it was like that
that is what I wanted we are taking them
back in time they have lost that time
it's gone forgotten but I'm able to
bring that back to them at least for a
little while but you don't need a PhD to
see the real benefits of a robot oh
thank you pepper I like you too with a
heart bye bye
uh-haul all right our next story is
about a high school senior with autism
who received a big surprise during band
practice Keith Russell from our CBS
Dallas Fort Worth station has the story
as Brandon Fisher II marches into his
senior year at DeSoto High School he
continues to play out his lifelong motto
it's become the best person that I can
ever be
I mean you only live once so I have to
make it great just as unique as
Brandon's story is his instrument called
the baritone euphonium this is a valves
instrument where it's similar to the
tuba and the trumpet French horn perhaps
an instrument Brandon has mastered as he
has everything else in life
Texas Southern University and the
University of Arkansas and both of those
schools offer Brandon Fisher and for a
ride scholarship
[Applause]
he is easily the hardest working student
in our Band program easily he just works
unlike any other like he's he's a beast
that's the best way to put it next ready
pushing everything hasn't always been
music to the ears of Brandon Fisher II
on the autism spectrum since he was a
child and that's come with its own
challenges it's pretty much having extra
intelligence at the cost of
some social ability
like tending to be socially awkward
to some people but certainly not to the
people who matter most we didn't start
with what you can't do we started with
what you can do and if you apply
yourself to do it how everything could
be possible Brandon has excelled in
engineering and he scored a 1290 on the
SAT his story will reverberate Way
Beyond his time on the leadership team
of the DeSoto High School band
it's something that should sound the
message that success is always
attainable
[Music]
it doesn't challenge you it doesn't
change you like you have to be able to
adapt to challenge
you have to be able to overcome the
challenge and once you do it it'll make
you feel awesome
if it doesn't challenge it it doesn't
change it wise words and that is our
show I hope it brightened your day and
lifted you up I'm confident it did if it
didn't though you know what I always say
reruns are free I'm gonna go find some
good news see you next time
[Music]
foreign